votre chaîne public sénat aujourd'hui a
déjà 20 ans je me souviens qu'il y a 20
ans en avril 2020 je signe et je
négocier comme dirigeants de france 2 ce
qui était un premier protocole d'accord
avec ce qui s'appelait encore à l'époque
la chaîne parlementaire sénat est depuis
20 ans on le sait tous
beaucoup de choses se sont passées en
général et dans le secteur médias en
particulier cette chaîne bien sûr a
touché sa fréquence tnt en 2006 qui lui
a donné une visibilité une notoriété
extrêmement importante mais aussi durant
cette période on a vu la multiplication
du nombre de chaînes gratuites
on a vu la multiplication du nombre de
chaînes d'information et on a vu
naturellement l'avènement du numérique
et des réseaux sociaux et dans cet
environnement multiples hyper
concurrentiel
d'une certaine façon ne pas évoluer
suffisamment vite c'est déjà prendre le
risque de reculer et je crois que cette
chaîne a aujourd'hui besoin d'un souffle
nouveau
je pense qu'elle a besoin d'un nouvel
élan et je vais essayer de vous
présenter mon projet à travers les
quatre axes qui vous ont qui vous sont
présentés le premier de ces axes
consiste à bien définir à la fois le
positionnement et la spécificité de
cette chaîne en effet face à ce nouvel
environnement hyper confidences hyper
concurrentiel il faut bien que public
sénat réussissent à préserver à défendre
son identité
on sait qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de
médias et par exemple les chaînes
d'infos dans cette surenchère ont
tendance à hausser le ton je pense au
contraire que public sénat peut
parfaitement être le lieu d'un dialogue
d'un dialogue constructif d'un dialogue
apaisé et civilisé c'est un espace
possible dans l'univers audiovisuel
français public sénat la chaîne du sénat
je vous apprendrai pas grand chose mais
cela veut dire très concrètement pour
son positionnement pour son identité
qu'elle doit naturellement traiter de
l'actualité mais qu'elle doit surtout
traiter de l'actualité du sénat et
parler des territoires
pour cela elle doit faire son travail de
chaînes parlementaires
je dirais sans complexe et même en le
revendiquant parler des territoires on
le sait la france ne se résume pas à
paris les territoires sont multiples
variées urbains ruraux en métropole et
dans les territoires d'outre-mer
les français ont les goûts de ses
territoires on le sait il suffit de voir
le succès de certains journaux
quotidiens à la télévision qui en
donnent largement compte et qui ont un
succès extrêmement important je crois
donc pour cette chaîne parler des
territoires c'est en vérité un atout et
une distinction pour public sénat sur la
chaîne sénatoriales on doit voir et
entendre des sénateurs et des sénatrices
bien évidemment on doit aller voir comme
dans leurs activités à paris ou dans
leur territoire
on doit également les avoir comme
invités comme expert dans les émissions
quotidiennes et on doit également les
avoir comme invitée dans ces mêmes
émissions quotidiennes
chaque année l'ensemble des 348
sénatrices et sénateurs doit avoir au
moins une exposition sur un des médias
de public sénat
tel est mon engagement parler des
territoires traiter de l'actualité du
sénat l'actualité parlementaire ce n'est
pas à vous que je dirais celle du sénat
est permanente
le travail des commissions le travail
législatif les commission denquête
l'émission d'information le travail des
délégations les questions d'actualité au
gouvernement c'est une matière
extrêmement riche extrêmement dense
il est d'ailleurs sans doute elle est
tellement dense sans doute peut-être
difficile en permanence de de savoir
tout ce qui se passe mais c'est le rôle
de cette rédaction c'est le rôle de
cette chaîne et pour moi c'est au coeur
de sa mission le sénat de son côté a
repensé au cours des dernières années
l'organisation de ces travaux à travers
notamment une modernisation de ses
rapports l'accroissement des captations
des auditions qui naturellement
constituent une matière première
précieuse pour cette chaîne également le
développement des travaux
troll cela a permis à cette assemblée de
mieux interagir avec les attentes des
citoyens
eh bien je crois qu'aujourd'hui public
sénat devrait m'en faire le lien entre
ces travaux et ses attentes et faciliter
l'accès à l'information
je vais vous donner un exemple simple
chaque semaine le sénat des sénateurs
font des propositions qui intéresse tous
les français dans leur vie quotidienne
eh bien il faut que cela soit l'antenne
de public sénat dans un programme qui
pourrait s'intituler par exemple le
sénat et vous la publie la chaîne public
sénat
toujours dans ce positionnement est en
finirait sur ce point là doit être une
chaîne citoyenne elle doit être un
rempart pour la démocratie
représentative par rapport à la
démocratie d'opinion
c'est une façon pour la chaîne de faire
voir sa différence par rapport aux
médias publics et privés notamment parce
qu'elle a une exigence légale
d'impartialité elle est la seule en
france à l'avoir et c'est précieux je
pense à un moment où les médias on le
sait ont de plus en plus de mal à faire
face à la défiance du public à leur
égard le deuxième axe vise à apporter à
la chaîne au programme une visibilité
une modernité plus forte sur ce point là
je pense qu'il doit y avoir des
évolutions à la fois sur la forme et sur
le fond je dirais que les programmes et
c'est peut-être leur travers de public
sénat sont parfois un peu trop sérieux
je ne parle pas du fond je parle de la
forme
or nous sommes dans un monde de la
télévision qui est ainsi fait que la
concurrence est forte que les choix sont
multiples et donc il est extrêmement
important d'être dans les bons codes de
télévision que ce soit pour la décor
pour la narration pour la réalisation
pour le rythme des évolutions des
émissions tout cela évolue très vite et
même si la chaîne public sénat
différents elle ne peut pas faire
l'économie dans sa proposition de cette
modernité dans son identité visuelle
je donnerai juste à titre d'exemple le
fait qu'aujourd'hui les visages qui
incarne l'écran elle a toujours été un
endroit pour faire découvrir des
nouveaux talents
c'est son adn d'origine mais il n'y a
pas aujourd'hui véritablement de figure
identifié du grand public
or ces figures identifiés ont intérêt
d'amener plus facilement d'identifier la
chaîne de donner confiance au public
alors entendons-nous bien il s'agit pas
de faire la course aux stars ce n'est ni
dans les budgets ni dans l'esprit de la
chaîne mais dans le passé ça a été le
cas il ya eu des personnalités reconnues
de l'audiovisuel qui sont venus dans un
projet qui les intéressait enfin je
pense qu'en ce qui concerne les experts
et journalistes invités à l'antenne il
faudra continuer à travailler sur un
profil plus diversifiée et notamment
prenant mieux en compte la diversité
en ce qui concerne les deux principales
émissions quotidiennes de la chaîne
l'émission de la matinale bonjour chez
vous et celle allons plus loin je crois
que parce que justement elles sont
largement diffusés sur la chaîne
il est important de les faire évoluer
pour qu'elle soit encore plus riche et
plus dense et naturellement public sénat
doit être plus que jamais la chaîne des
territoires et donc les partenariats
noués avec lui nier loup par donc ce
mois les partenariats liés avec la
presse quotidienne régionale avec les
radios en région doivent aussi à mon
sens être approfondies janvier un
présent au troisième axe celui concerne
la volonté d'accentuer l'empreinte
numérique de la chaîne notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux
entendons nous bien aujourd'hui le
premier canal de diffusion de cette
chaîne c'est bien sûr le canal tnt
et naturellement il faut le privilégié
mais on sait que l'évolution et l'avenir
de la tnt sont des choses qu'ils ne sont
pas à ce stade totalement prévisibles il
faut donc continuer à investir fortement
sur les autres modes de diffusion et
notamment sur les modes de diffusion
numérique
donc je pense qu'il faut des formats
plus variés sur cet univers là et je
propose donc une stratégie fondée sur la
marque public sénat favorisant une hyper
distribution des programmes afin de
rattraper notamment un retard sur les
réseaux sociaux et sur les applications
sur les réseaux sociaux je constate que
le sénat comme anne comme assembler à
une avance notamment sur twitter
dans une audience très large je constate
au contraire que la chaîne public sénat
notamment par rapport à son homologue
lcp de l'assemblée nationale n'a pas
nécessairement la tête mais même
performance sur ses raisons donc je
pense que sur ses réseaux pour améliorer
la performance
il ya une grammaire propre il faut pas
se contenter beaucoup de rediffuser les
problèmes
r mais il faut véritablement faire des
formats et des programmes spécifiques
pour ces réseaux c'est comme ça qu'on
trouvera davantage de résonance et c'est
important notamment vis-à-vis des
publics jeunes vous le savez j'observe
aussi que la chaîne n'a pas de mobilité
d'applications en mobilité je pense que
c'est un sujet qui doit être en tout cas
examinés et enfin toujours dans
l'empreinte numérique et pour finir sur
ce point là je dirais il ya une
initiative à mon sens ce qui peut être
pris qui pourrait s'appeler public local
et qui constituerait à faire une
plateforme agglomérant des programmes de
la chaîne elle même en territoire en
région également des programmes de ses
partenaires de la pqr la chaîne ayant un
rôle à ce moment-là d'agrégateur deux
partenaires sur ce sujet et janvier
enfin à mon dernier axe qui concerne le
projet d'entreprise
je dirais premier point nous ont
peut-être l'occasion d'en parler
ce projet doit être fait à budget
constant mais pour cela je les dis il
faut prendre des nouvelles initiatives
numériques des nouvelles initiatives sur
les programmes
donc je propose une méthode dont pour
aller là détaillé si vous voulez qu'ils
s'appellent budget base zéro et qui
permet en vérité de réexaminer toutes
les dépenses en se reposant permanence
la question de leur fondement mais une
chaîne ce n'est pas seulement des coûts
c'est aussi des personnes qui
travaillent c'est une valeur ajoutée
très forte de cette chaîne
évidemment un réseau de talent j'entends
bien je les fais tout dans toutes les
entreprises que j'ai dirigé être le
garant de la paix sociale pour
l'ensemble des équipes de public sénat
et enfin je finirai sur ce point là
au-delà des enjeux naturellement de
parité de diversité fondamental pour
cette chaîne de par son image même la
question de l'exigence delà de toute
forme de lutte contre les violences
sexuelles au travail
au delà de tout ça si on veut se
redonner des marges de manoeuvre je
crois qu'il faut remettre sur la table
le travail de synergie avec la chaîne de
l'assemblée nationale lcp entendons nous
bien pas des synergies des
rapprochements à n'importe quel coup je
dis très clairement et cela figure dans
mon projet que la fusion n'est pas dans
mon projet je ne suis pas l'homme qui
fera la fusion d'ailleurs ça ne dépend
pas du président de la chaîne mais ça
dépend d'abord des instances
la de l'assemblée mais je veux dire que
si on veut retrouver des marges de
manoeuvre
il ya sans doute moyen de relancer un
processus de coopération qui aujourd'hui
me semble proche disons de l'immobilisme
du point zéro et je m'engagerai en tout
cas a relancé une démarche constructive
sur ce terrain là merci merci monsieur
bell délit et donc sans plus attendre
nous allons passer à la série de
questions réponses
elle va durer environ 25 minutes et
c'est madame fillol qui va poser la
première question oui merci madame la
présidente
cher monsieur vous avez déjà évoqué ces
sujets dans votre présentation mais je
me permets d'y revenir pour vous quels
sont les principaux enjeux et défis de
public sénat dans le paysage audiovisuel
actuelle comment définiriez-vous ses
missions intrinsèque et qu'est ce qui la
différencie des autres chaînes en
particulier les chaînes d'information
mais également lcp assemblée nationale
dont vous venez juste de parler
merci beaucoup merci madame la sénatrice
donc sur le premier point je finis juste
de noter votre troisième question
les principaux enjeux
clairement si je devais il y en a
beaucoup naturellement mais je vais
aller sur les principaux le premier je
les dis aujourd'hui cette chaîne à une
fréquence tnt c'est extrêmement précieux
mais la tnt n'a pas un avenir sans
limite
il ya sans doute un rendez vous prévu
dès 2025 et il pourrait y avoir une
extension de la tnt en 2030 donc je
pense qu'il est plus que jamais
indispensable de vraiment développer la
marque public sénat au delà de la chaîne
strictement de la développer à travers
des contenus et d'utiliser aujourd'hui
tous les modes de diffusion que nous
avons sur les contenus les réseaux
sociaux bien sûr facebook twitter mais
également dans certains cas cela peut
être d accord avec des plateformes de
diffusion comme la plateforme salto
comme je propose aussi dans mon rapport
de faire des podcasts chaîne ne fait pas
et qui est véritablement un
développement très fort aujourd'hui de
nouveaux contenus très simple pas cher à
faire on fait des podcasts c'est à dire
du ch ont enregistré ensuite on le
diffuse sur des plateformes par exemple
france radio france à une plateforme
très performante en matière de podcasts
donc je pense vraiment d'où l'idée aussi
de cette plateforme publique locale je
pense que il faut vraiment aller plus
loin mettre plus de moyens humains et
financiers
c'est ce que je disais dans le fait on
sait que les moyens sont constants donc
il faut faire des choix mais je crois
qu'il faut développer la diffusion de la
marque et de toutes ses formes de
programmes adaptés sur différentes
plateformes saas et le premier enjeu le
deuxième enjeu je les dis aussi c'est
que je crois qu'aujourd'hui il faut pas
sous-estimer la le canal lui même qui
est quand même le canal le plus vu de
l'ensemble des médias qu'à cette chaîne
et je pense que sur le canal il ya un
travail c'est quand on a deux émissions
quotidiennes la matinale et puis
l'émission du choirat non plus loin
qu'ils sont beaucoup rediffuser je pense
qu'il faut vraiment un travail très fin
je ne sais peut-être pas le lieu ici
mais je pourrais rentrer dedans là aussi
à la fois sur la forme et sur le fond
pour essayer que ces émissions apporte
vraiment tout ce qu'elles peuvent tout
ce qu'elles peuvent apporter je pense
que le façon globale il ya une petite
si on de modernité qui se pose parce que
encore une fois dans le monde de la
télévision on est dans un monde de
zapping
les gens ne vont pas toujours justes sur
votre chaîne sur la rive mais souvent il
passe d'une chaîne à l'autre et donc il
ya des choix des codes couleurs parfois
qui sont pas nécessairement les plus
attractifs le deuxième point je sais que
peut-être deux le deuxième point ce sont
les missions intrinsèque
alors que l'émission intrinsèque je les
dis pour moi c'est une chaîne
parlementaire une chaîne parlementaire
c'est d'abord une chaîne parlementaire
c'est à dire c'est d'abord une chaîne
qui rencontrent des travaux du sénat
il est en permanence dans cette maison
il ya en ce moment donné un exemple en
ce moment il ya je crois à deux missions
qui travaille sur les questions de la
jeunesse des étudiants d'une part des
étudiants et d'autre part des jeunes en
général étudiants opa étudiants avec tes
problèmes d'inégalité voilà un sujet
majeur pour notre pays prenez un sujet
que la panda me a encore accéléré je
pense que aussi bien sur le site que sur
la chaîne elle même avec des travaux
aussi riche qui s'étale durant des
semaines et des mois
je pense qu'il ya vraiment une matière
très importante et je les dis c'est
cette dimension de chaînes
parlementaires chaîne décès d'un des
sénateurs chaîne des travaux du sénat
alors ça n'empêche pas aussi le côté
chaîne civique c'est important chaîne
d'actualité je ferai peut-être le lien
avec la troisième question
bien sûr cette chaîne traite de
l'actualité sauf qu'aujourd'hui des
chaînes d'actualité
vous en avez un nombre mais sûrement de
pays qui doivent voir leur corps et
toutes accessibles en gratuit en tnt on
en a au moins quatre on en a cinq six
donc à l'arrivée c'est un domaine
extrêmement concurrentiel et on le voit
bien il se fond de concurrence beaucoup
dans la chute dans la surenchère
donc je pense de ce point de vue là que
public sénat a vraiment une carte
différente à jouer elle ne doit pas trop
singer essayer de faire une course à
l'échalote avec les chaînes d'info je ne
crois pas ça mais elle traite de
l'actualité
donc je pense qu'elle veut faire
entendre sa différence peut-être par
plus de profondeur dans ses analyses
et là encore une fois il peut s'appuyer
sur les travaux du sénat
je pense de façon générale que elle peut
véritablement c'est d'ailleurs une des
raisons pour lesquelles je présente pro
ce projet c'est ce qui m'intéresse dans
cette chaîne
je pense qu'elle peut vraiment dans cet
univers je pense qu'elle peut vraiment
avoir un rôle un ton un style différent
et le dernier point si vous permettez
différence avec lcp
je dirais très simplement le sénat et
l'assemblée sont deux assemblées
représentatives mais elles ont un style
différent et je pense que ceci on doit
on doit le voir sur chacune des chaînes
monsieur daldry je donne la parole à
monsieur pierre laurin
merci madame la présidente bonjour
monsieur baldelli
j'avais prévu de vous interroger sur
l'évolution que vous envisagez des
modalités de diffusion vous avez déjà
deux reprises aborder ce sujet et à
l'instant juste pourrait insister et
clarifier les choses sur l'avenir de la
de la tnt du canal 13 parce que vous
avez dit à l'instant que vous pensiez
qu'il n'était pas éternel donc qu'est ce
que ça veut dire dans votre esprit sur
les modes alternatifs de diffusion vous
avez donné vous avez donné plusieurs
exemples
est-ce que vous pouvez développer en
point là dessus notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux et avec quels objectifs
de diversification de renforcement du
public
vous envisagez cette diversification des
utilisations des modes de diffusion
alors d'abord sur le premier point
monsieur le président très important
l'avenir de la tnt je voudrais plutôt
être rassurant d'abord je suis
absolument si j'ose dire pro tnt parce
que d'abord c'est gratuit c'est non
identifiables c'est à dire la différence
de quand vous êtes abonné un opérateur
télécom qui vous fournit la télévision
quand vous regardez atc de les retient
personne ne sait ce que vous regardez
quand vous le regardez et par ailleurs
c'est gratuit donc je pense que la
france a beaucoup développé la tnt à la
différence souvent d'autres pays
européens d'où la difficulté par rapport
au fait que la tnt est potentiellement
un jour menacé mais en tout cas je
considère que c'est un atout très fort
pour la france très fort pour cette
chaîne est donc en tout état de cause il
faut j'ose dire se battre pour qu'on ait
la tnt le plus longtemps
une fois qu'on a dit ça la difficulté
c'est que ce sont évidemment des
fréquences que d'autres acteurs
opérateurs souvent je suis pas expert là
mais souvent télécoms vise à un moment
donné et c'est au niveau de la
commission européenne où il cherche
toujours à organiser un moment on l'a vu
dans le passé sur d'autres fréquences
une extinction dans chaque pays pour
pouvoir récupérer ces fréquences donc je
disais il y à ma connaissance un rendez
vous prévu en 2025
mais normalement pas d'extinction avant
2030 au plus tôt donc ça veut dire que
ça normalement ça nous donne encore
largement de la marge
donc ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point c'est le des modes
alternatifs de diffusion alors ils sont
de deux ordres
d'abord un peu se rassurer le jour où la
tnt s'arrêtera les chaînes linéaires
continueront à être diffusé pour le
compte par les acteurs télécoms qui
fournissent dans le même abonnement de
la télévision du téléphone et de
l'internet
c'est déjà aujourd'hui à peu près 70 %
de la consommation des français parce
par ce mode de diffusion l'a donc le
jour où la tnt s'arrête si elle s'arrête
un jour
pour autant public sénat aura toujours
un canal de diffusion comme elle l'a
déjà aujourd'hui chez ces opérateurs
mais la force de du bouquet tnt c'est
que ces opérateurs de par la loi sont
obligés de le reprendre telle qu'elle
est dans le même ordre et dans la même
numérotation ça c'est extrêmement
précieux c'est un atout formidable pour
cette chaîne sur vos deux autres
questions donc les modes de diffusion
alternatif the lady naturellement en
linéaire les opérateurs télécoms
mais en non linéaire évidemment twitter
facebook les nouveaux réseaux sociaux
qui arrive si on met des contenus
s'il est public sénat qui correspondent
à public sénat on peut cela déjà fait
aujourd'hui naturellement mais on peut
plus largement utilisé ces contenus
diffusion qui ont quand même et ça
renvoie à votre troisième partie de
votre question sur la diversification du
public
évidemment on est là sur des publics
souvent plus jeunes encore que il faut
pas croire que en font chaud de la
journée utilise pas aujourd'hui ça se
développe largement mais
structurellement on est sur des publics
plus jeunes donc ça permet aussi par
rapport à la tnt en étant présent en
numérique en ayant une empreinte plus
forte en numérique sur ces réseaux
d'aller aussi chercher des publics plus
jeunes
merci nous passons à la question de
monsieur loïc hervé monsieur baldelli
dans un contexte budgétaire contraint
comment comptez vous mettra en valeur à
l'antenne de public sénat
tous les territoires vous avez évoqué
cette question dans votre propos
liminaire avec la question toute
particulière des outre mer en prenant en
compte la couverture sur le terrain de
l'activité des sénatrices et des
sénateurs dans l'exercice de leur mandat
même si le mot a été prononcé plus en
voix par vous comment bien assurer
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
à l'antenne alors sur le premier point
oui
au total si vous voulez garder du temps
pour la conclusion il nous reste trois
questions encore d'accord merci alors
sur le sur le premier point sur les
territoires naturellement vous avez
raison envoyer des équipes des
journalistes en territoire a priori ce à
un coût supplémentaire parce qu'elle le
temps du transport et du voyage il ya
plusieurs façons malgré tout de traiter
ça d'abord on a des partenariats avec
des titres de pqr ou des télévisions
locales donc on peut aussi se mettre
d'accord dans certains cas sur des
reportages partager et puis je crois
qu'il faut le faire je crois qu'il faut
l'assumer dans le dans le budget de la
chaîne alors ça veut pas dire je vais
dire à l'outre-mer si on prend l'exemple
de l'outre-mer aujourd'hui il y à un
magazine positive outre mer je crois
d'ailleurs qu'il n'est pas fait par les
journalistes de la chaîne mais qu'il est
sous traitée à une agence de production
il est assez courant en forme à l'idée
sur un bon principe qui est montrant les
choses positives sur l'outre-mer ya
joaillier 1 à la réunion un sujet sur
des vélos électriques assez intéressant
mais une fois qu'on a dit ça je crois
qu'il faut aussi accepter pour
l'outre-mer dans certains cas de voir
les difficultés
prenons un exemple la question du
logement outre-mer je crois que la
délégation la question de la
représentation sur les télévisions de
l'outre-mer là aussi la délégation de
l'outre-mer c'est des sujets dont elle
tait emparés ces des sujets sur lequel
je travaille je pense qu'on peut aussi
parler de boutre maires à paris avec la
délégation sur la question égalité
hommes-femmes peut-être alors chers
question égalité homme femme
objectivement quand je regarde l'antenne
et des principales émissions y en a un
certain nombre qui sont présentés par
des par des femmes mais ce que j'observe
c'est que naturellement dans ses
émissions interviennent et c'est normal
beaucoup de gens je parle pas des
invités mais je parle d'experts je parle
de journalistes qui sont sur des médias
de pqr partenaires et là j'ai pas le
décompte mais en regardant cette chaîne
je ne suis pas sûr que dans ce cadre là
on soit dans la parité je pense qu'on
est quand même assez masculin alors
sûrement que des efforts sont faits mais
je pense qu'on peut aller plus loin
la parole est à madame nathalie delaître
merci madame la présidente monsieur
baldelli j'ai lu avec grand intérêt
votre projet votre curriculum vitae deux
questions me sont venues spontanément la
première quelle est votre activité
depuis votre départ de m6 en 2019 et la
deuxième vous êtes passé par rtl une
grosse entreprise vous avez souhaité
diriger france télévisions plus de dix
mille personnes
et là vous souhaitez arrivait à public
sénat qui somme toute une petite pme à
côté pourquoi ce choix
merci alors madame la présidente pour
répondre à votre première question mais
vous y trouverez un peu la réponse à la
deuxième mais je répondrais expressément
la deuxième j'ai fait le choix après
avoir quitté effectivement le groupe m6
et la direction de rtl j'ai fait le
choix de me présenter à france
télévisions je me suis retrouvé en
situation finalement de ne pas être
choisi à la fin du mois de juillet
dernier et est depuis je suis à la
recherche d'un emploi mais je j'ai
toujours fonctionné en coup de coeur par
envie et j'en viens à la deuxième
question la question de la taille est
pas une question qui pour moi importe
beaucoup
pourquoi dans ma vie professionnelle
j'ai commencé dans cette maison comme
administrateur ou au sénat j'ai en
permanence fait des périodes dans le
secteur public et des périodes dans le
privé là je sors de 15 ans donc privé
j'étais très heureux j'étais beaucoup de
choses c'était vraiment très intéressant
de travailler toutes ces équipes mais
quand j'ai quitté ce groupe là pourquoi
j'ai décidé de me présenter à france
télévision parce que j'avais vraiment le
sentiment pour faire simple que
l'évolution du secteur privé en
télévision est une évolution qui va
peut-être est certainement vers moins de
sens et je pense que plus que jamais
dans notre société telle qu'elle évolue
le sens on en a besoin en tout cas moi
dans ma vie professionnelle je suis un
moment où je ne suis plus dans des
logiques car irissou de carrière ce qui
m'intéresse c'est si je peux donner du
sens c'est ce que je fais et ça a été le
sens de ma candidature à france
télévision parce que je connais bien
le secteur public pour avoir passé
notamment près de sept ans dans groupe
français evian a dirigé france 2 et donc
j'avais quelques idées sur ce que l'on
pouvait faire sans doute mieux sur le
secteur public
aujourd'hui vous avez raison public
sénat d'une chaîne plus petit mais si je
regarde le budget des programmes ce
n'est pas rien j'ai dirigé dans groupe
m6 plusieurs chaînes paris première et
teva qui avait cet ordre de but de
budget de programme et je sais qu'on
peut faire beaucoup de choses avec ces
moyens là qui ne sont pas qui ne sont
pas négligeables et je pense vraiment
que ce qui compte le plus c'est l'envi
et c'est le chance quand on peut donner
du sens à son travail
c'est une chance formidable beaucoup de
gens y aspirent beaucoup de gens n'y
arrive pas toujours
moi j'ai peut-être un peu la chance
aujourd'hui de pouvoir me le permettre
en tout cas c'est une préoccupation
importante pour moi et je considère que
les médias en général et
particulièrement les médias publics ont
véritablement un rôle très important à
jouer dans le fonctionnement d'une
démocratie
merci je donne la parole à madame
jacqueline eustache brinio merci mme la
présidente
je veux revenir quelques instants aux
yeux sur votre projet stratégique
ce projet stratégique à sa lecture
comporte peu de propositions concrètes
concernant la couverture des travaux
parlementaires et celles de l'activité
dessinateur dans l'exercice de leur
mandat et dans leur territoire
alors il ya des constats généraux que
nous partageons bien évidemment est-ce
que pourriez nous vous pourriez nous
précisez vos propositions éditoriales
pourvu qu cenal ans est maintenant la
matière s'il vous plaît je n'ai pas eu
accès et je ne sais pas si elles
existent aux audiences des émissions
donc je n'ai pas voulu c'est toujours
très difficile on va pas changer une
émission si elle fonctionne bien et si
les gens la trouve intéressante donc
pour vraiment avant de savoir ce qu'on
peut faire de différent et c'est la
raison pour laquelle j'aurais très bien
pu faire une grille de programme et vous
dire comme j'ai dirigé rtl géant
quelques années changer 100% des
programmes et moi j'adore faire ça
et à côté du côté dirigeants j'y
reviendrai je suis aussi un homme de
programme mais je pense qu'aujourd'hui
avant de dire on va changer ceci et cela
il faut un peu respectée les programmes
existants les gens qui les font donc il
faut se faire une analyse plus précise
ce faire une analyse plus précise il
faut quand même à bord l'audience de ses
programmes
je ne sais pas aujourd'hui où en est
cette chaîne en termes d'audience qui
fait froid en france c'est médiamétrie
je ne sais pas aujourd'hui quelle est
l'audience de ses programmes
maintenant j'ai fait des propositions
néanmoins sur les programmes et j'y
reviendrai et on peut en faire d'autres
j'ai fait la proposition d'un programme
qui s'appellerait le sénat et vous parce
que je pense comme je le disais que en
permanence dans cette maison il y à
travers des propositions de loi à
travers des missions d'information à
travers parfois des questions écrites ou
orales des sujets très concrets qui
concerne les français qui peuvent les
intéresser je pense que c'est important
d'avoir un module qui permet de le voir
je vous donne un exemple je crois que
c'est une initiative sénatoriales gay
une proposition de loi qui a été fait
pour que les véhicules de collection
puisse continuer à circuler dans les
zones urbaines qui sont des zones
préservées en terme en termes
d'environnement
et bien cette proposition de là je crois
qu'elle vit sa vie je serai ce ne soit
définitivement adopté en tout cas voilà
typiquement quelque chose ça concerne
peut-être une population limitée mais
plein de petites briques montre que à
l'arrivée le sénat concerne
potentiellement dans ses actions dans
ses décisions
tous les français ça c'est un exemple
l'autre exemple je les dis je pourrais
rentrer dans le détail mais ce n'est
peut-être pas le lieu
je pense que l'émission
qui fait la matinale de public sénat
ainsi que l'émission disons plus de
débats allons plus loin du soir je pense
qu'il ya un travail non négligeable à
faire sur ces émissions
merci monsieur baldelli est pour la suze
et moi si mon père dans des modèles la
présidente je vais plus à votre
conclusion mais et je pense aussi mais
ça ça mérite peut-être d'en discuter
davantage avec les sénatrices et les
sénateurs je pense qu'une émission sur
les mers qui est pour part défiant
quelque chose que vous connaissez très
bien parce que souvent vous l'avez été
où c'est vos interlocuteurs
je pense qu'une émission sur les mers
serait aussi très intéressante parce que
là on aurait une diversité formidable
pour le compte en terme de territoire en
termes de taille de ville etc et en
termes d'activité on peut parler de tout
en parlant d'une ville et en parlant ils
s'emmerdent peut parler de sanitaires
mais un jour on peut aussi parler
d'autre chose et pour conclure les
questions mais ce quelqu'un est là
merci madame la présidente monsieur
baldelli votre projet présente des
propositions assez précises dans
documents écrits en ce qui concerne le
contrôle de gestion et le suivi de la
dépense notamment la proposition vous
avez d'ailleurs abordé je crois tout à
l'heure d'un budget on base 0 pouvez
vous nous préciser votre démarche
notamment les conséquences éventuelles
en matière de ressources humaines et
ensuite quelles marges identifiez vous
d'ores et déjà pour améliorer et
éventuellement la gestion alors le
budget de base 0 je leur dis peut-être
en un mot ça consiste à se dire
aujourd'hui un budget il ya une chaîne
qui fonctionne c'est ce qui s'est
accumulée en 20 ans avec plein de
décision si aujourd'hui on devait faire
cette chaîne ex nihilo on réexamine
toutes les dépenses est ce qu'on ferait
la même chose parce qu'on ferait
différemment
en tout cas ça permet d'avoir des
analyses ça permet de voir des marges
après on décide de les utiliser ou de ne
pas les utiliser
donc soyons clairs là dessus par rapport
à la deuxième partie de votre question
je les dis aujourd'hui je ne connais pas
le budget de cette chaîne j'en connais
le montant global je n'en connais pas le
détail donc je ne peux pas aujourd'hui
je le ferais assez facilement quand
j'examinerai ce budget si je suis amené
à l'examiner je les fais sous le trou
dans ma vie professionnelle mais
aujourd'hui je ne peux pas vous dire sur
ce budget quelles sont les marges
puisque je n'y ai pas eu accès
mais en revanche je les dis dans un
budget il n'y a pas qu'un budget il ya
des personnes qui travaillent à des
personnels
c'est bien sûr un coût mais c'est ce qui
fait que la chaîne existe et sur ce
sujet là je les ai toujours fait dans
les entreprises que j'ai dirigé publics
comme privés je suis garant du dialogue
social c'est à dire je pense savoir
discuter avec les personnels pour
trouver les bonnes solutions et pas des
solutions qui ne leur conviennent pas
j'ai oublié il y avait je crois un
dernier point dans votre question
monsieur le questeur donc est ce que ta
valise on savoir si vous aviez déjà
identifié des démarches je crois que
vous avez répondu mais ce baldelli vous
reste donc à conclure dans la limite des
40 minutes qui vous sont impartis et
donc à écouter sans plus attendre nous
vous laissant la parole et nous vous
écoutons alors j'ai combien de temps
exactement ça se termine à 40 minutes
donc j'aurai peut-être minutes voilà je
pense que je vaux libérerait plutôt jeu
comme j'ai eu l'occasion de vous dire
j'ai commencé ma vie de professionnel
dans cette maison puisque j'étais
administrateur d'abord la commission des
affaires économiques puis à la
commission des finances c'est d'ailleurs
dans cette maison quelque part que j'ai
découvert le l'intérêt qui n'a pu
quitter ensuite du secteur audiovisuel
puisque j'ai eu le privilège de
travailler avec le sénateur jean cluzel
qui était le rapporteur éminemment
reconnu de ce secteur c'est lui qui m'a
tout appris
c'est lui qui m'a permis de comprendre
ces entreprises de rencontre les enjeux
de ces entreprises et de rencontrer les
gens qui les dirigeait j'ai vraiment ce
que j'ai appris au sénat j'ai appris de
l'exigence du travail
j'ai appris l'intérêt du bicamérisme
derrière l'intérêt du bicamérisme en
réalité c'est la capacité canton
administrateurs haute au sénat on
travaille avec des sénateurs de tous les
bords politiques et donc on est là pour
travailler avec eux et quelque part les
aider dans ce qu'ils veulent dire dans
un rapport dans un projet de loi est
donc pour moi les questions de de
pluralisme les questions de
compréhension des autres
les questions de tenir compte de toutes
les opinions sont des sujets essentiels
je les ai vraiment dans ma vie
personnelle et dans ma vie
professionnelle
j'aime travailler ensemble j'aime
débattre j'aime écouter les opinions des
autres et le cas échéant surtout quand
elles ne sont pas les mêmes que les
vôtres
parce que c'est ça qui permet d'évoluer
ou d'en changer
et ça je crois que grâce au sénat je les
fait durant les plus de vingt ans où
j'ai dirigé des entreprises en télé en
radio en numérique ce véritablement ça
se constituer une partie de ma façon de
voir j'ai toujours veillé dans ses
médias à respecter tous les équipes
d'opinion j'ai toujours considéré que
ces médias il faut dire cette idée des
grands médias nationaux avaient vocation
à s'adresser à tout le monde sans
exclusive et je crois profondément au
respect du pluralisme et d'ailleurs
quand on prend la chaîne public sénat
elle a une particularité c'est qu'elle
n'est pas contrôlée sur champ pluralisme
par le csa la différence de tous les
autres médias
mais en revanche elle a une exigence
plus forte qui est une exigence légale
qui figure dans la loi modifiée de 1986
puisque c'est l'exigence de
l'impartialité c'est une exigence très
forte plus forte aujourd'hui en france
ni les chaînes publiques ni les chaînes
privées non une exigence aussi forte
il faut aller à l'étranger c'est la bbc
qui dans sa charte à une exigence
d'impartialité
donc je crois que ça ce sont des choses
qui sont pour moi essentiel dans tout
médias parce que c'est comme ça que des
médias réussissent à être respecté et à
être crédible auprès de nos concitoyens
le deuxième point je les dis vous le
savez je suis un manager excusez-moi de
l'anglicisme je suis un gestionnaire
mais j'aime profondément travailler au
contact de mes équipes c'est là que j'ai
toujours éprouvé le plus de plaisir de
satisfaction je suis pas de ce point de
vue là un manager hors sol distance je
suis un manager impliqués
ce qui m'intéresse c'est le travail de
tous les jours avec les équipes c'est
monteiro ce sont mes équipes c'est là
que le travail est agréable et c'est les
même quand on a des difficultés
évidemment quand on va faire face mais
c'est ça qui nous c'est ça qui nous
enrichit je suis aussi un président qui
a toujours su faire évoluer les
entreprises qui doit diriger publics
comme privés notamment sur les questions
de numérique si je prends l'exemple de
france télévisions au début des années
j'ai mis en place et dirigé la filiale
france télévisions interactive
si je prends rtl j'ai beaucoup
développée sur rtl l'info numérique de
telle sorte que airtel est rentré dans
le top 10 de l'info numérique en france
si je regarde le groupe m6 est moins
inquiet conçu avec mes équipes et lancer
la première offre deux podcasts de ce
groupe mais je suis aussi un homme de
programme et un homme de contenus
c'est au fond ce qui m'intéresse le plus
dans un média parce que c'est dans ce
qu'on donne à voir dans ce qu'on montre
c'est là que se crée le lien avec nos
concitoyens c'est là qu'on peut donner
du sens c'est là qu'on peut leur
apporter quelque chose
et quand je dirige et rtl je n'étais pas
seulement président de rtl
j'ai aussi très largement changer les
programmes la grille et parce qu'en
réalité
parallèlement ge est également moi même
le directeur des programmes aidant le
groupe m6 j'étais pas seulement
vice-président du groupe
mais j'étais également le dirigeant en
charge de l'ensemble de l'information du
groupe que ce soit en radio en
télévision ou en numérique
pour finir je dirais que public sénat a
une utilité certaine et une singularité
c'est pour ça que cela mérite que l'on
s'y intéresse
c'est pour ça si je puis me permettre
que je m'intéresse à public sénat parce
que j'ai envie de mettre toute mon envie
mais aussi mon expérience au service de
ce projet que je vous ai présenté
je pense que cette chaîne a besoin d'une
visibilité une modernité qu'elle mérite
et qu'il faut sans toujours dans cet
univers média qui va très vite qu'il
faut sans cesse réussir à mettre en
avant à montrer et à démontrer je crois
que le sénat a un rôle essentiel à jouer
dans no 1
tution dans les valeurs républicaines et
vous me permettrait de finir devant vous
en citant victor hugo victor hugo avait
dit aux sénateurs montrer que vous êtes
nécessaire ça remonte à bien longtemps
ils ont largement montré depuis eh bien
moi je souhaite que public sénat montre
également plus que jamais qu'elle est
nécessaire
merci
[Musique]